hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com
so as usual i'm here with you guys to
make some technical analysis
i'm here to show you everything that is
working for me that i've been using for
many years as a professional trader all
the different tools and techniques
that i like to associate together to
build my scenarios and select my
preferred one
so in my videos i try to explain as good
as i can why
this is working how to choose what is
working the best
in the different kind of situations that
you can have
in the markets and today i want to make
a big update guys on
amc let's get into it
[Music]
all right so my previous video guys i
was basically showing you my different
scenarios so
let me remind you quickly here what they
are let me take a little step back here
guys all right so this is amc guys you
know for the past six months so this is
just extremely bullish as you can see
just look at the macd
guys you know you can just you know i
like to check if i have any divergence
for those who are watching my videos for
some time you know
that i'm always checking if i see some
divergences and when i see some i
you know i'm a bit worried and i you
know try to think
what this can mean what are maybe the
alternative scenarios that are maybe
less
bullish than i think that can happen and
when i
look at this bam market making high
highs i want to see the macd
making a high high as well and this is
not a high high it's uh
you know just extremely high high this
is very good this is showing you guys
you know in the longer term
even on the hourly time frame that this
market has
a lot of energy to give and if i check
on the daily let me see
and guys on the daily of course it's
working as well it's even
you know higher the macd going from two
to
ten times top five when the market 25
times 3.5 roughly you know the highs so
this is very good guys this is this
means that
this market is blowing up so it's good
guys it's very good so i like to see
this kind of divergence on the longer
term
i'm having here you know my earlier 12
counting that is you know fitting
very well guys and once again i always
say this but keep in mind that when
something is working you need to keep
using it
and here elliot wave is giving me very
good
signals one two three four five
we gonna have this fixed wave guys it
really looks good to me so of course
sometimes you have truncated fixed waves
you know you can have a look
here you know this is something that
happens all right so there is no
guarantee
so elliot used the word failure to
describe a situation in which the fifth
wave
does not move beyond the end of the
third we prefer the less connotative
term
truncation or truncated fifths this can
happen i've seen
sometimes the situation happening is
that you have one two three four
everything looks good you have the
volumes you have you know the breakouts
properly
everywhere and you can break down the
third wave into five waves just like i
did everything looks good and still
you're gonna have this fifth wave that
is
failing that is truncated so this can
happen just keep this in mind but
it's very unlikely very unlikely and i
don't think it's gonna happen here and
i explained to you guys step by step the
reason why
so now let me come back to my preferred
scenarios so i have two scenarios
basically playing out so once again guys
here i spotted an exaggerated divergence
that is basically
less powerful than the regular bearish
divergence or the hidden bearish
divergence but it's still a bit
creating some bearish signals here
and this is the only bearish signal i
have but my bullish signals as that we
are holding above the 50 moving average
on the hourly time frame that is very
good
we are above the 61.8
percent retracement of the first wave
the first wave is perfectly broken down
into five waves
my breakout here occurred with the
strongest volume we saw
in the past weeks it was this it was
here guys
so everything looks good to me my
preferred scenario
is this one that we finished the one
we're making the two
we are in the third wave and the third
wave is just you know like this one
two three four five all right this is my
preferred scenario so let's see if this
happens
and my alternative scenario guys is once
again
this one pam pam that this is an abc all
right basically
so the c wave can go here the c way you
know it's basically a bit my lower level
basically guys you need to keep an eye
on the 50 moving average if we break it
you know once again with some volumes
guys here there was a fake out
go check my other video uh how to avoid
this kind of fake outs guys it's not
that complicated you just need to be
aware that
volumes are very important in breakouts
otherwise it's not a breakout
and here this was not a breakout it was
a fake out
and yeah so if we break this guys with
some volumes then probably we're going
to go to the 48 area
so this is not my preferred scenario but
it's an alternative scenario that is
unfortunately quite possible given the
exaggerated
bearish divergence that i'm having here
but even if we go here guys don't worry
bam we're gonna bounce back and go to
the
100 area first and then 135 this is my
scenario
so now let me show you guys the
financial data that i'm having
for you so first let's have a look guys
at the option markets
so i updated already this data guys you
can see we were here at 23
in my last video why we came back to 12
guys 12 of synthetic short interest of
maximum synthetic shot interest
we are consuming 10 out of this 12 but
we were consuming 20 out of 23
go check my other videos the reason why
guys is very easy
is that the june expiry has occurred and
there was
a lot of exposure on this expiry
and so what happened here is that
basically there was around 45 million
shares
uh equivalent on this expiry and they
have not
been rolled it means that people who
were long some calls
they just let it expire so maybe they
bought some shares against it that's
possible but they didn't buy calls
so it's too early to say exactly what
happened here i would need to have the
15th
of june data published here uh to know
the short interest because basically
a few scenarios can happen in this
situation but one of them
is just that the apes kept buying some
shares
and that the market makers the hedge
funds just kept the short position
against it or
uh maybe they bought some shares but
they you know we have around 250 million
shares trading every day so 45 million
is just around 15 20 of this
so maybe they just bought some shares
and there was some seller against it
so it's not enough for me to analyze
what happened but for now what i can
tell you guys is that the total short
interest
dropped from 40 or 35 last week 40
it was to 30 percent but once again this
data is not fresh
so i need to see what is the short
interest here it's going to be published
i think in five days or something like
this i'm gonna update you guys as soon
as it is published
and we're gonna analyze what it means
now let me go back here guys
so how do you think this is looking to
me it's looking good guys
it's looking good so here we are at 60 i
have
this 70 strike call that is growing uh
even if the june expiry has passed we
still have around 5 million shares here
and the 145 call is growing as well
we had 13 million last time now having
only eight million but there was seven
million
uh eight million under june expiry so
basically
everything after june grew from six
million to eight million so it's still
growing
and if you have a look at where it's
coming from because it's very
interesting
half of this 8 million shares is coming
from the july maturity with the
volatility at 309
so this volatility is dropping little
bit guys so this is
you know i prefer to see it growing but
you know it's still around 300
so it's still quite big and you can see
that there is a lot of
this options that actually come from
here and here what is it it's the
jan 22 expiry guys so six months
so this is telling you that the bullish
momentum
is not only on the short term it's on
the longer term as well so this story is
going to last guys all right
we might not see this big squeeze
happening
right now or maybe we would and then we
would have one more squeeze
i don't know but what i'm seeing here is
that
we are having options on every maturity
even on the longer term
and the volatilities are high everywhere
i guess you know
here we were at 140 150 something like
this
so it's dropping a little bit but it's
still very high 135 percent guys
on the gen 23 maturity this is the gen
23 maturity it's
a lot guys you can also you know have a
look at the delta which is very
interesting so delta basically is the
probability we finish in the money this
is not what market makers
use to protect themselves you know they
sell calls and they buy some shells
and they buy the delta percentage of
shares and you can see that for example
for the september maturity the delta of
the 145
strike call is 55
guys so there is basically 55 chance
that we close above 145
in september guys in three months
according to market makers
so this is very good information guys
and this is the kind of information that
you want to use if you make some option
strategy
so here let me show you again a small
option strategy guys
that i showed you last time and i know
that maybe i didn't explain good enough
because this is maybe new to you guys
so let me explain better so first thing
i go
on yahoo finance get the prices so i go
on the options
once again guys i'm gonna build my
strategy on the july maturity why july
because it's gonna be cheap it's gonna
be cheap guys and you know
the kind of strategies i build are cheap
and you can roll it if your scenario
doesn't happen in june
like the one i showed you last time then
you do the same in july
that's it okay we take all these options
okay i only need up to the 70 strike
we copy this we paste it here
we use the price that is the average
of the bid and the offer guys because
once again the last trading price
is sometimes not the same as the fair
price
and we start to build our strategy so i
want to show you guys so basically my
scenario is that we go 235 we know that
we have
very high volatilities on the upside on
the 135 strike
so basically i will show you again the
condor strategy which is made
of four legs here i have only three so
let me add
one leg so i built my new payoff guys
so now let me show you the condo
strategy so once again to make a condor
basically this strategy
is based on finding an area where the
spot is going to trade
at a given time and when the volatility
is very high
it's very hard to find it but when you
use technical analysis
actually it's you know it becomes less
difficult
but in terms of probability is very low
that's why this kind of payoff is very
cheap
so i want to make for example something
that is
starting to make money at for example 90
then 135 145 all right
so when you just buy one call just your
payoff is like this guys all right so
this is just a call so once again let me
remind you guys what is a call option
it's a strategy that is paying the
performance above a given level
at a given time so for example the 90
strike hole is something that is going
to pay
everything above 90 in july so for
example if you finish 110
you're gonna make 1 000 us dollars
because you're spending 800 us dollars
to buy
your call option so basically you're
making around 2 000 but you spend 800
so the profit would be 1 000 us dollars
for example
now if you cap it you sell the highest
try call
then you're not going to make anything
above 100 so then you have a code spread
you know something that is looking like
this
this is a call spread so you buy here
and then you sell here so when you sell
you have one option going like here like
this one option going like this so
basically the sum of it
is flat then you sell one more at 125
and you cap it with the 145 and
you having this counter strategy and
just
you see here we don't see the 145 strike
now we see it and so here for only 100
us
dollars guys let's let me do it this
time 10
if you spend 800 us dollars guys you can
make up to
9 000 so this is a very profitable
strategy
and you know you have a range of strikes
so here between 100
and 135 that is making your profit
maximal and guys this is my scenario so
this is the kind of strategy i would put
in place you just buy this
stuff you know you buy here sell here
sell here and buy here
in terms of margin it's usually
compensated on
with your broker so he will allow you to
sell here and sell here if you bought
here and here
because basically your loss is here
capped so you don't require a lot of
margin
so this is the kind of strategies i
would like to make because it's cheap
and
it can make a lot of profits so i hope
you guys enjoyed this video
and i hope that i managed to explain to
you how to make some cool option
strategies based on your technical
analysis
and if you did enjoy this video please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys